hey youtubers is Charlie this is gonna
be my Winter Soldier review I know a lot
of you who have been asking for it for a
while but we just got it in the United
States because reasons so because this
is also my bonus Marvel movie video for
this week I'll be talking about how it
interacts with the other Marvel movies
going on and in case you didn't know
agents of shield next week is gonna
follow up directly on the events that
happen in the end of this movie be sure
to subscribe to get my video if you're
finding me for the first time and feel
free to suggest what you think my next
bonus Marvel movie video should be about
so time to speechify some Winter Soldier
I'm gonna start with my top 5 moments
then I'll do my review and then I'll
talk about interactions with other
Marvel movies so careful for spoilers if
you haven't seen it yet but here all
wait just a second here we go number 5
the Arnim Zola reveal anyone who's read
the Winter Soldier comic was totally not
surprised by any of this but there's a
couple reasons why this was really
awesome and super important for what's
gonna happen next year in age of Ultron
but it was so funny watching Captain
America react to him after punching that
monitor that's one of the things that
gets overlooked when you talk about
these kinds of movies the humor the
comedy in this movie was mostly a
continuation of the jokes you saw in
Avengers you know Captain America
reacting to things that would actually
make a really awesome fine brothers
video Captain America reacts to the
internet of all the things he reacted to
you know him reacting to Arnim Zola was
one of the best the other big thing to
take away from this is the concept of AI
in the Marvel Universe I'm talking about
Ultron next year
Arnim Zola basically uploaded his
consciousness into those data banks do
not get me started on the potholes and
why he didn't jump from system to the
system but think about this algorithm -
that he created and how it relates to
Ultron's core operating mission get rid
of all humans I'll talk more about that
after my review when I'm talking about
other Marvel movies number four all of
the Captain America Winter Soldier fight
scenes if it wasn't clear the Winter
Soldier is totally juiced up on Super
Soldier Serum just like Captain America
not the same one that he got but Bucky
for all intents and purposes is just as
quick and just as strong watching two
super fast super strong people fight is
really hard to pull off without looking
ridiculous but they did an amazing job
think about it from another angle
what
and the person you were fighting never
got tired and we're almost
indestructible it's like the Hulk
fighting Thor it could totally look like
comedy if you're not careful
obviously in Avengers they made those to
fight in it was supposed to be funny you
know like when the Hulk tried to pick up
his hammer but in Winter Soldier it's
meant to be so much more personal so it
ended up being then tumbling all over
each other and a wave of Steel punches
and shield bashes I thought that those
fight scenes you know that cap Winter
Soldier fight scenes were so much more
fun to watch than the big CG action
sequences you know like with the
helicarrier's and Falcon flying around
number three the amazing Black Widow
character development in case you didn't
know Black Widow is probably going to be
the first female standalone movie
they're gonna do no release date
announced but after this movie she'll
have way more time baking in the oven on
screen than any other female Marvel
character and as much as I want to see
her in a Phase three movie it does feel
like Doctor Strange and Black Panther
are better candidates it was really the
task of this movie to make her character
feel like a real person in Avengers she
was forced to share all that screen time
with the dream team so with the
exception of her Hulk and her Loki
scenes
she was pretty forgettable along with
Hawkeye but Winter Soldier was totally a
black widow slam-dunk Scarlett Johansson
is a great actress and I think she just
got a chance in this movie to be a
person as opposed to window dressing so
I'm gonna say Black Widow movie talk for
a future video but essentially after
Avengers 2 or Avengers 3 it's definitely
gonna happen for her number 2 the
Avengers age of Ultron post-credit scene
the age of miracles I just love that
Baron von Strucker line if he didn't
catch it too he's basically treating
Hydra the same way that the Red Skull
treated Hitler in the Nazis in that
first Captain America movie it's like
he's playing on a whole other evil level
when he talked about shield in Hydra
being two sides of a coin that's no
longer currency he was foreshadowing the
Galactic conflict that the infinity gems
are gonna bring it was also kind of
timely given that we have the first
galactic Marvel movie coming in the fall
consider the bar for superhero wow
factor officially raised as for the
special effects for Quicksilver and
Scarlet Witch I thought they were
interesting they've already taken a ton
of pictures of them on the set of age of
Ultron I'm gonna withhold judgment on
those too until I see them with complete
special effects and color grading though
that's just basically what they make the
movie look all shiny and nice but here's
the weird part because Marvel can't use
the word mutant and they can't use
Magneto they're changing their
backstories which is a little weird for
their characters but I'm gonna withhold
judgment until I actually see the movie
and my number one moment
Captain America totally destroyed shield
he had a little help
but with Nick Fury going after Hydra
survivors guerrilla style and everyone
kind of going their separate ways it
seems like shield will be in rebuilding
mode for a long time and all this Hydra
stuff going on is basically the
explanation for why they weren't in Thor
the dark world or Iron Man 3 they kind
of blew up the Triskelion tube but what
I think is gonna end up happening after
this is that Maria Hill will kind of
take over the home base day-to-day while
Nick Fury is off the grid but there's
still all those other shield agents like
Sharon Carter and everyone on agents of
shield I'll talk more about the blowback
from this as it affects other Marvel
movies and TV plots but this was such a
huge deal I'll be super pissed if shield
is totally back to normal by the time
age of Ultron rolls around Marvel does a
really great job with continuity so I
don't think that's gonna be the case but
now it's your turn let me know what was
your favorite moment and how long do you
think it's gonna be before shield
repairs itself before we'll see a shield
in another big movie I totally gave the
movie a solid a as an amazing follow-up
to the Avengers it's really like the
most direct sequel to an Avengers movie
that there's been ironed Man and Thor by
themselves always had very little
interaction with shield at an
organizational level but Captain America
has basically been working for them ever
since the Avengers I loved how they
paired him with Black Widow in this
movie - it's funny to see how the tone
of the story changes based on which
Avengers you pair together the movie
itself was all about identity but it
didn't completely answer the biggest
question that it asked you know Who am I
which is totally why we all have to go
see the next movie with those characters
which is age of Ultron of course I was
happy to see that they didn't try to
cram too many expositional bits in for
all those other movies which was great
but how about that Doctor Strange name
dropped from Sitwell may he rest in
pieces doesn't that make you feel like
Doctor Strange is definitely coming in
phase 3 one of the best things about
Winter Soldier though was just how
different it was from Thor or Iron Man
or even the last Captain America movie
the first movie was really like a period
war drama
this was a political thriller that just
had amazing action I think them doing is
that a thriller also made them work that
much harder at the dialog and it just
paid off brilliantly punching and
kicking stuff is a lot of fun to watch
but you know I'm not ten years old
anymore so I need amazing characters to
keep me watching and just like in my top
moments you know Black Widow the captain
Anthony Mackie they were all great Nick
Fury had about as many lines as he
usually gets but Samuel Jackson can do a
lot with just a look you know he doesn't
need that long speech the only thing
that I didn't like was the Larry Sanders
Park I don't know why of all things to
call back to in old movies they decided
to use him but I feel like he was just
absolutely awful there was also a few
problems with Arnim Zola logically if he
was an AI and was affecting all of
shield systems
why didn't he move his consciousness to
the cloud back in the 70s pre-internet
yes yeah he would have been stuck in
that basement but now in the age of
information and distributed processing
why didn't he just live on servers all
over the globe I think the answer to
that is that they wanted to say that
kind of spectacle for Ultron and
Avengers 2 but let me know what your
final thoughts are on the movie you know
love it or hate it what we really need
to talk about now is how everything that
happened affects what's coming next
namely age of Ultron agents of shield
season 2 and Captain America 3 so right
off the bat let's talk about Arnim
Zola's algorithm as it applies to Ultron
the algorithm was designed to evaluate
the sum total of everyone's lives and
the planet and assess them as threats
Ultron in the comics decides that humans
in general are just too big of a threat
to be allowed to live you know thus his
kill all humans mission begins here's
the big question does that mean that
Arnim Zola's algorithm is going to be
what evolves into ultron ultimately I
don't think that's the case the rumor is
is that all tron will be an AI created
for the military that just becomes
self-aware like Skynet and does what
machines do creates the most efficient
system possible and humans being
fundamentally flawed just aren't part of
that equation but the idea of how Arnim
Zola's algorithm worked though I feel
like is a spiritual if not literal
prequel to what Ultron is gonna be onto
characters though Quicksilver and
Scarlet Witch looked like they had the
same type of brainwashing treatment
Bucky got their supposedly actually
going to be fighting the Avengers the
first time they meet in age of Ultron
but you know eventually they'll get full
into the roster and hopefully go on to
appear in Avengers 3 I just love how von
strucker's said that he was basically
going to throw all those other Hydra
teams under the bus to throw a shield
off his scent but now we have to mention
the Knicks Captain America movie because
that's definitely gonna happen in Phase
three there's actually a lot of
interesting directions that can take
based on the events of this movie but
there's been a lot of rumors that
they're gonna do a version of the death
of Captain America story and now a
rehabilitated Bucky is just gonna take
his place temporarily I've already
talked a lot about potential Captain
America three stories so I'll post a
link to that video at the end of this
one of all the other Marvel things that
are happening though agents of shield is
left in the weirdest place after this
movie after season one shield basically
will not exist for a while so does that
mean that if the show gets a season two
they'll spend that year on the hunt for
Hydra remnants like Nick Fury or are
they going to be helping to rebuild
shield at home now that Cobie Smulders
is done with How I Met Your Mother I'm
really hoping that she's gonna join the
cast full-time as Maria Hill she's
basically like one movie behind Black
Widow in terms of character development
you know you start as window dressing
then you get the background part and
then you get center stage be sure to let
me know though if you want to see Maria
Hill become part of agents of shield
full-time because I think that'd be
awesome
so in other news remember Winter Soldier
follow up in next week's agents of
shield be sure to subscribe to get my
video I'm also posting my arrow Q&A
later today in the meantime you can
click here to learn more about Avengers
2 and you can click here to get my top 5
Captain America 3 stories thank you so
much for watching I hope you guys all
enjoyed Winter Soldier I'll see you
tomorrow high fives
you